s
États-Unis.
Romain Schué.
(en espagnol)
- Jesus ne sait pas qu'il a
devant lui un journaliste qui
On est à Toronto et Jesus est
un passeur, qui propose à des
Mexicains de quitter le Canada,
pour entrer illégalement
aux États-Unis.
Cet homme a l'habitude
d'organiser ces voyages
vers le Québec.
Ces migrants mexicains
et ces passeurs arrivent ensuite
ici, autour du lac Champlain,
en Montérégie, à quelques pas
Des voitures les conduisent
dans ces champs, d
agricoles et ils courent
ensuite vers les États-Unis.
mexicaine a fait le trajet
au mois de juin.
américains, en partant du
Mexique,r au Canada
et finalement aux États-Unis.
Yazuri a finalement été arrêtée
Dans les derniers mois,
le nombre d'arrestations
dans ce secteur est en constante
augmentation. De 61 en mars, on
est passé à 178 aplique
notamment par l'annulation
en 2016 en 2016 en 2016 en 2016e
pour les Mexicains souhaitant
visiter le Canada.
avocat en immigration
- Au lieu de fairesée
du désert, comme on dit, bien
les gens passent de cette façon,
sécuritaire pour eux, quoique
illégale, évidemment.vernement a
que les enquêtes
sur ces réseaux de clandestinss)
Selon le ministre de la Sécuritr
d'investir, mais compte
des informations avec
les Américains, pour démanteler
ces réseaux à la frontière.
Radio-Canada, Mon